6 44 here on a wednesday morning it's
time for our morning cup of joe's
segment with metro sheriff joe lombardo
we'll point out though this interview
was taped before this morning's officer
involved shooting
so we only have a few weeks left in the
school year ccsd says it wants to have
all of its students
back in class 100 percent in the next
school year in august
what discussions has metro started
having already with ccsd police
about the fall and about the look at
schools when the new year starts
yeah that's a constant conversation and
and i i got my fingers crossed hopefully
we do get all the
the students back into school at 100
percent and i think that's very
important for
their well-being their mindset and also
for the
families to be able to lack of a better
word babysit them
or have them to get the opportunity to
go back to work themselves and deal with
their life and
everything that goes along with it so
the most volatile or the most concerning
for us is to start a school when the
students are going to school and when
the students leave school
that seems to be when there's anxiety
emotion and trouble
associated with the students for us to
be concerned with so
you know and clark county school
district police are aware of that
and we work in conjunction with them we
have that omni presence
you know around the schools during those
time periods and we
are well involved when they do
extracurricular activities such as
football games and everything else that
goes along with it
that's not something you can ignore
because it's it's you know
used and emotionally and devil's
workshop with their hands if they're not
doing anything
to release their tensions and everything
else goes along with it
it's a it's a very important
consideration for us especially for the
school district police
and i don't want people in the community
to lose sight of that you know there's
there's conversations about getting
ready for the police and
in the school environment and i think
that would be a very uh
bad mistake i think it's a very
necessary entity
within that environment for for
everybody to feel safe and be successful
one thing that we hear a lot of
certainly when we're working on the
morning show
overnight we hear the scanners and these
reports of illegal shootings around the
valley
we've talked before about the shot
spotter technology what should folks in
the valley do
if they think they're hearing gunshots
in their neighborhood so they can stay
safe call us i mean that's a simple
answer i mean
a lot of things that we investigate or
successfully investigate is based on
pattern
if it's a one-off event it's very hard
for us to investigate and determine who
the perpetrator is but
and when we have numerous phone calls
and uh numerous people giving us
little bits of information that we can
compile together
uh it makes it a lot easier for us to
find the perpetrator and and it's
important for people to call us
it's just important for us to know that
because you mentioned the shot spotter
technology that's only in limited areas
in town
so it's not all-encompassing and it's
very important for us to have that
bigger
picture if you hear something if you see
something say something the same thing
goes if you hear something as well
sheriff lombardo thank you for joining
us again this morning we always
appreciate it you can submit some
questions for the sheriff yourself if
you'd like just head to 8newsnow.com
find out if your question is answered
every wednesday